bist auch überall wo ich bin überall
mein der servus ja
der sehr schön das war der Graf und
jetzt kommt
selig die kommen aber jetzt erst zu mir
ach
so hieren also pass auf ja komm bleib
hier sitzen darf ich vorstellen das ist
der Kollege von Sat 1 im
Frühstücksfernsehen aber der kommt nach
uns ja
logisch so wir sind hier mit selig im
greenro wobei ich mich immer frage warum
das Ding Green Room heißt weil es ist ja
überhaupt nicht green habt ihr überhaupt
eine Erklärung dafür das ist wie ein
darkro für Leute die noch grün hinter
den Ohren sind okay
m ihr habt einen super Song auch
komponiert hier für den Bundesvision
Song Contest hattet ihr das schon im
Kopf als ihr von Ewigkeit zu Ewigkeit
in eure Feder hab laufen lassen oder wie
wie war das nee wir haben eigentlich
wollten wir ein anderes Lied hier
performen das hat nicht hingehauen weil
das Lied von Ewigkeit zu Ewigkeit ist
tatsächlich etwas manisch meditatives
irgendwie was es im Fernsehen selten zu
sehen und zu hören gibt und wir dachten
wir geben der Fernsehgesellschaft mal
die Chance irgendwie auch auch solche
Lieder zu genießen zu können das hört
sich aber jetzt nach dem Motto an wir
haben keine Chance nutzen wir sie nicht
nee doch nee aber genau das ich meine
genau das das das Unterbewusstsein
manipulieren mit diesem Lied also ich
glaube das ich rechne uns groß ja ich
rechne uns da sehr große Chancen ein hat
dieser Mann schon mal so geredet du
wirkst jetzt nicht nee ich hö das zum
ersten Mal aber ich finde das sehr
interessant und glaube auch da ist
vielleicht was dran jedenfalls ist es
ist bei uns selber wenn wir auf der
Bühne stehen und diese Show eben geprobt
haben es wird ein ganz schummrig durch
diese ganzen Sachen da die da passieren
wir merken schon eine Band ist immer
auch eine automatisch eine multiple
Persönlichkeit wie kommt ihr damit
zurecht wir genießen die psychodelischen
Erfahrungen dadurch okay okay und die
wollte offensicht den Publikum auch
weitergeben mit von Ewigkeit zu Ewigkeit
das ist unsere Aufgabe ist eure aufgab
außerdem wird es extrem spannend morgen
es gibt so ein kleines Gefahrenpotenzial
das müssen wir mal gucken ob wir das
bewältigen weil welches
Gefahrenpotenzial ist das ist das die
Show oder ist das GFF oder sowas nicht
bei
alles ihr Können auch nicht sagen worauf
die Leute achten sollen Gott bewahre
okay okay was sagt ihr denn warum sollen
sie für euch Woten die wissen ja gar
nicht dass sie für uns Woten das ist die
machen das ja unterbewusst also die
wissen ja die wissen ja gar nicht die
wissen ja gar nicht was sie da
tun tun meine Frage ist tretet ihr
überhaupt noch auf oder wird er vorher
eingeliefert so und ich habe für euch
eine geniale Überraschung weil der
stärkste Kanal oder einer der stärksten
Kanäle ich will jetzt nichts falsches
sagen aus Hamburg unterstützt euch es
ist Simon desessio mit halfcast Germany
was sagt ihr dazu Alter Kick die Styles
Alter Hamburg ist fette fette Nummer und
wir sind dabei und
das ist gut so hallo Welt mein Name ist
Simon des hier und ich habe was tolles
zu sagen und zwar tritt eine schöne
Hamburger Gruppe auf dem bundesfen
songkontest an und das ist die Gruppe
seelig ja die Gruppe seelig und schön
als Hamburger Jung oder stütze ich die
Jungs natürlich jungs ihr habt meinen zu
Beistand wie heißt das weistand nein ich
bin natürlich für euch ist klar als
Hamburger Jung bin ich für euch ich
drücke euch fest die Daumen und ich
hoffe alle anderen Hamburger drücken
Euch auch die Daumen ich denke mal
natürlich tun sie es und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher ihr werdet gewinnen denn
ich werde mindestens 80.000 mal anrufen
wenn nicht noch realistischer 90.000 mal
und ich denke ihr werdet viel Spaß haben
dabei wie gesagt ich drü euch Daum und
ja Leute favorisiert das Video gibt das
ein Daumen hoch damit wir vorher schon
mal sehen können wer so viel leichter
gewinnen wird weißt du je nachdem mit
den anderen und so ihr wisst Bescheid
Sim ich habe meiner Gruppe viel Glück
gewünscht Hamburg sagt viel
Glück danke Leute dass ihr uns wählt das
ist richtig von euch das ist gut das ist
sehr gut so wir wir wir geben unser
Bestes winning team danke
danke